>> Whitney Burton.
>> Hi.
I'm Juan.
>> I'm from the United States.
>> And I'm from Argentina.
>> And we would like to say in 2008 we think
there needs to be more
of a concentration on education especially
for children in developing
countries who aren't given that opportunity.
>> We must not only invest in education but
at the same time in
sustainable economic development in these
countries by boosting
agriculture but by creating awareness of their
value of education in
their future but at the same time create -- strengthening
the
institutions and creating employment for the
people not to leave a
country afterwards and have their grades who
are no longer a grade
problem that is grades.
>> Yeah.
A lot of times they will become educated and
because there's not the
economic stability or the economic institutions
or infrastructures in
the country, there's no place for them really
to go and so if you
create economic incentives and economic programs
that people can then
go and use then they won't have to leave.
They can stay in their country and they can
continue to make their
country a better place and irradicate poverty
essentially in their
area.
>> The main problem with training is that
people from the developing
country go to another developed countries
and all the innovations, all
the good ideas that they have implemented
in the developed world and
developed country, not producing enough management
and not producing
enough development in their own country and
that's why one of the key
questions in addressing the poverty issues
in this country is not only
investing in education but strengthening in
the institutions, the
infrastructure -- building infrastructure,
and also at the same time,
as we have said before, by creation of employment
for the people not
to leave the country and could have a good
work in their own country.
>> Exactly.
Now, every year in North America we spend
$20 billion on ice cream.
It would only cost $10 billion to build enough
schools for all the
world's children in school.
So think about that the next time you buy
ice cream.
Think about the little actions you can do
that can really change the
world 'cause there's a lot we can do through
charities, through NGOs,
through UN, through so many organizations.
You can change the world every day on a daily
basis by simply deciding
not to eat ice cream one day and donating
the money to build a school
or to loan out for someone to start a company
or a business.
>> The main we must not only rely on the government
to
solve all or problems but we must be an integral
part of solving that
problem.
It's only through the advance of the individuals
of the governments
that we can tackle the major world problem
such as poverty, and lack
of education, global warming.
We should act as a community respecting each
and other's favors.
>> Thank you so much and have a great day.
Bye.
>> Bye.
We challenge you, Davos.